Le neuf/06 prochain auront lieu les élections
européennes. Concrètement, comment ça se passe ?
Je t'explique ça en moins de 30secondes.
Si tu es inscrit sur les listes électorales et que
tu as plus de 18 ans,
tu pourras donc aller voter pour élire des députés qui
représenteront pendant 5 ans.
Tu n'es pas inscrit ? Pas de panique,
tu peux toujours le faire jusqu'au 1ère mai en ligne
et jusqu'au 3 mai.
En mai, tu es inscrit,
tu pourras donc voter pour la liste de ton choix.
Chaque liste obtenant 5% des voies
pourra donc envoyer des députés au parlement
proportionnellement au nombre de voies obtenues.
Ces élections européennes sont les plus
importantes de notre histoire,
c'est pour cela que je dois te dire que les 9 ans,
nous avons le temps d'Europe.